bonjour et bienvenue sur chaque académie
pour cette vidéo spéciale championnat du
monde de bonnes 2008 nous avons
aujourd'hui comme invité nicolas la
vallée bonjour nicolas bonjour janvier
que bonjour à tous
donc nicolas toi tu es donc un amateur
d'échecs et tu as déjà beaucoup donné
dans le milieu des d'échec
oui bah écoute à cirebon j'étais joueur
de compétition j'ai effectivement 2160
lots dont 15 maisons comme on m'a dit
raisonnable qui lui en lots fidelin et
l'international j'étais impliqué sur
munitions qui s'appelait dire une activi
donc effectivement j'ai eu l'occasion de
commenter avec stéphane laborde et loire
aux langes quelques parties d'échecs
elle donc c'est un petit retour sans
prétention mais avec plaisir donc je
suis très heureux de pouvoir commenter
avec un grand m avec toi cette partie du
championnat du monde
crânement comme nick allende voilà donc
nicolas qui m'a beaucoup aidé pour créer
donc le site et chaque académie on a
fait pas mal de trucs ensemble et je
t'ai choisi pour ses deux premières
parties parce que tu es donc l'élève
type au dessus je sais que tu vas me
poser les bonnes questions
ça commence bien que tu veux essayer
alors kramnik pour cette première partie
a joué son coup favori le coup et 4
donc là pour l'instant pas de surprise à
nom de la jouer également sa défense
favorite la défense czeslaw donc la
défense l'a tout simplement caractérisé
par de cette structure la défaite et
hisse donc on s'attend un milieu de jeu
assez serré on va dire dieu très fermé
exactement donc chronique joue cavalier
ces trois heures de coups on lie arrière
on peut commencer par cavalier f3 pour
l'instant il est très important est la
première surprise en ce match que
cramique décident d'échanger au centre
qu'il simplifie la position au centre
alors ça ça me paraît quand même très
surprenant parce que c'est quand même un
match pour le championnat du monde jouée
une ouverture de cette de cet acabit
avec les blancs une variante des changes
pareil quand même stratégiquement
étrange jean luc un à tout à fait pour
cette position
je pense que trame unique donc c'est pas
super envie de montrer ses cartes dans
la première partie est disons voilà je
dirais que ce n'est pas un début qui est
très ambitieux mais peut-être que kramis
que nous réserve quelques surprises
voilà donc on va voir donc faux s4 le
développement classique et cavaliers ses
6 e 3 donc maintenant on constate
plantes comme les noirs sont débarrassés
du plan sur ces six et ils peuvent se
développer naturellement donc avec leurs
cavaliers sur l'a46
oui à noter que le développement du fou
donc rend les quatre est logique au
regard de la structure de pions on sait
que l'on va avoir une chaîne d43 donc le
fou pour éviter d'être enfermé et bien
cramique joue très tôt dans l'ouverture
f4 en plus c'est vrai que c'est une
jolie diagonale oui le fou qui est placé
sur cette grande diagonale est toujours
très utile dans cette variante
éventuellement le fou peut s'échanger en
d6 mais ce serait ça sera au bénin
landes et noir cet avantage pour les
blancs se fout en tout cas maintenant
une fois qu'il est sorti il libère la
colonne c'est pour la tour voilà donc on
va voir si effectivement le trou le fou
trouve des objectifs mais c'est une
vision une case de développement assez
naturel voilà tout à fait donc fouillé
pts 5
l'asymétrie entre les joueurs jouent
position symétrique
là on vient de jouer cette coupe c'est
au blond de jouer donc la force dans
cette ouverture ce n'est pas
l'occupation du centre
ce qu'on constate qu'elle est à peu près
égale de parts et d'autres vu la
symétrie
mais les blancs dans cette position vont
jouer sur leur avance de développement
donc il va vraiment donner une rupture
des symétries voilà je pense
qu'effectivement les blancs devraient
ici occupé assez rapidement la colonne
c'est je pense pour exercer une pression
sur sur 7 sur cette colonne on va voir
après comment les noirs vont réagir mais
bon pour l'instant c'est une guerre de
tranchées invisible
bon pour l'instant c'est rien
d'exceptionnel alors la cramif pour
profitent ils ont arrosé de bons joue un
coût qui est assez intéressant il joue
le ku'damm b3 d'hommes v3 tout
simplement c'est maintenant bon on
attaque le pion 17
on commence à placer un petit pot choses
sérieuses dans cette position ils
attaquent donc l'option 17 et on
constate que si on répète la position ça
peut être un avantage des blancs c'est à
dire peut-être al'avantage des liens on
sait en jouer dam des six il y aurait
peut-être un échange et les blancs
pourraient tout simplement casser un peu
la structure des pions en face voilà et
il joue et après sur la faiblesse la
faiblesse en fait dès 6 ans voilà tout à
fait donc d'accord donc en fait la
symétrie ça a du bon mais jusqu'à une
certaine limite en ayant exactement
alors je vais juste mettre ma fenêtre en
mode analyse module donc ça serait un
petit inconvénient donc après d'un bête
alors maintenant on va quand même
regarder l'historique de cette variante
parce qu'on est quand même là pour un
petit peu apprendre aux joueurs comment
jouer cette ouverture est là donc le
vieux coup c'est le coût des stocks qui
a qui a été joué en championnat du monde
dont qui a été jouée entre bout de binic
et al c'était en 1961 donc ça nous
rajeunit pas donc quoi cette position
derrière été joués par les plus grands
ça va donc jouer donc en 1931 c'était le
match revanche si on se rappelle à
l'époque talent avait été championne du
monde en 1960 et avait perdu son titre
lors du match revanche en 1961 et donc
binic avait quand même utiliser cette
arme pour gagner la grande époque des
échecs soviétique
ebony binic avait utilisé cette arme
pour gagner le j'imagine que le plan des
blancs et dans cette structure là c'est
d'essayer dé changer le fou de cases
blanches contenu canadien 6,6 pour
détériorer en fait la structure des
pions noirs et après essayer de faire
pression sur le plus faible qui
resteront c6 oui donc ça fait partie des
plans dont principalement donc le
premier plan c'est tout d'abord de
profiter donc du cloud h du cavalier
donc pour mettre la pression dans cette
position on constate peu en concluons
donc le cavalier sur ces six cavaliers
sur l'a46 on peut comment calais a amené
ses cavaliers ou cinq donc le cavalier
qui peut bien sûr la case de cinq et on
peut commencer à exercer une certaine
pression
sur la colonne s'est éventuellement si
on décide de prendre ceci se fera dans
un contexte qui permettra parce que le
pion probablement va reprendre sur ces 6
soit d'en raconter ce qui permettra donc
d'arriérés sautions de l'empêcher
davantage sur ces cinq soit 4 c 5 et de
libérer le jeune noir donc on va essayer
finalement de jouer cette position dans
un but positionnelle là par exemple un
coût qui est qui qui n'aurait aucun sens
ce serait tout simplement le coup elle
si ça le poids si ce qui provoque
finalement donc pour ceux ci c'est le
blocage du bio comme comme on voit que
le centre est relativement fermé en ce
qu'il y a des couilles en fait de cette
ce choix d'ouverture en général le jeu
se déporte plus ou moins sur les ailes
ont convoyé la stratégie des blancs se
serai d'attaqué sur les dames d'utiliser
le positionnement des pièces comme le
fou qui est actuellement f4 le cavani
qui peut sauter en e 5 e le clouage du
fourbe et cinq sur le calice et 6 avec
les tours et venir sur la colonne c'est
pour essayer d'exercer une grosse
pression sur les louis pour l'instant
d'action se passe principalement les
dames ce qui est typique d'un joueur
deux des quatre ans qui lui en général
l'intention de passer son roi à l'abri
en juin et de s'occuper donc d'une
faiblesse quelque part et là au centre
c'est bien verrouillé donc tout se passe
à la dame
alors en cette position le coût
principal c'est le coup cavaliers 17 mai
à l'époque le champion du monde en titre
pall l'année pas jouer les bons coups il
avait joué une erreur et la veille une
erreur et c'est devenu depuis cette
partie des rares classiques pour qu'on
va regarder il avait juifs p 4 il avait
continué à jouer d'asymétrie à jouer la
symétrie il avait été assez optimiste on
va dire cavaliers 5
quand la mode vinik avait décidé de
clouer donc de clouer le
le cavalier sur la casse et 6 on
constate qu'après un coup comme petit
rock par exemple perdre un pion français
ci s'appellera pions pas vraiment on
peut pas prendre le pion tout de suite
parce que si on prend j'imagine que le
fou va prendre sur ces trois donc six
cavaliers prendre donc toi tu pensais à
cavalier ans j'imagine puisque on
attaque la dame et là on peut peut-être
différents échecs intermédiaires et
après essayer de profiter donc de la
cavalier qui serait pas très très bien
placés dans ces six simples voilà donc
pour jouer une contre-pression
finalement sur le pion qui est en c3
voilà ça peut être maladroit par exemple
alors n'ont peut-être pas ce coup on va
peut-être jouer tout simplement comme
elle sait pas oui cette position 6 7 1
si on joue t mb 6 alors je vais juste
revenir un tout petit peu en arrière
donc sur cavaliers prend sur cavaliers
de france et six dans cette position eh
bien oui il faut prendre tout simplement
tiens ben non je crois que dans cette
position va tout simplement jouer d'amd
c'est bien de 17 femmes des faits c'est
vrai qu'avec les tours et venir sur la
colonne c'est la voix limbé et le roi
blanc qui n'a pas encore ok c'est
finalement presque une sorte de gambeat
c'est peut-être un peu tôt pour dire
pour le dire mais c'est quelque part une
initiative qui passerait dans du côté du
côté des noirs exactement
et je pense qu'effectivement ça devrait
largement compenser le pion au moins
parce que je vois pas comment depuis en
c3 va pouvoir tenir longtemps dans cette
situation oui exactement donc l'as bram
pour on imagine un coup comme cavalier
ou 5 la dame bien sûr des cinq pour
empêcher de roke est l'ardent fait
j'aime bien la position noir oui on doit
jouer dames 2 pour moquer et la dame
maintenant peut venir sur la case afin
par exemple pour attaquer le pion sur
ces trois avec une tour ensuite à venir
et grosse pression sur le pion à ré
arrière-plan donc on va revenir
l'arrière le bon coup dans sa position
après prix d'entrée 6 c'est de faire
tout simplement petit roquet
parce que comme le design the witch la
menace est plus forte que l'exécution on
nous menace d'attaquer ce pion
ces droits et si on pousse le pion et un
très joli coup donc si on décide de se
débarrasser de ces options seront jamais
une mauvaise stratégie là un excellent
coup dans cette position c'est le coup
cavaliers à 4 assez surprenant cavalia 4
qui est un coup très surprenant avec
tout simplement l'idée de jouer à trois
de chasser le fou et de prendre l'option
sur la caps et saint caprais avec un
cavalier qui serait vraiment très bien
placé et là nicolas après pions prend
des quatre il ya un très joli coup c'est
le cavalier c6 et là il ya une
fourchette entre la dame et le fou et on
ne peut pas défendre le fou et on ne
peut pas défendre le fossé énorme donc
la belle à la position donc là est
perdante elle a complètement
effectivement on est une pièce contre
deux pions je pense pas qu'on puisse
tenir très longtemps
côté côté noir voilà donc bon tu vas me
dire dans cette position c'est peut-être
pas très claire alors un coup par
exemple un coup comme en c3 dans cette
position ne ne donne pas grand chose on
peut peut-être même d'ailleurs prendre
tout de suite sur la case dans ce si on
joue qu'à y penser si si on peut prendre
comme ça et là cette position donne un
avantage aux blancs pourquoi parce que
le fou est très très bien placé il est
placé là et on exerce cette pression on
a le temps d'avant ce donc là par
exemple il faut défendre l'option ses
600 cavaliers qui attaquent depuis ses 6
avec damas quatre éventuel voilà et non
en madame acat et éventuellement ses
caps 8 ours et un lac et il va commencer
par à exercer la passion en premier donc
on va profiter de cette avance
développement donc là j'ai expliqué
pourquoi sa saga n'est pas tout
simplement à cause de cavalia 4 un
dernier petit coup amusant aussi donc
dans cette position après donc après
petit rock
si on joue tour c'est 8 il ya le coup g5
qui est intéressant c'est à dire qu'on
fait un développement qualitatif dans le
sens où j'ai deux fois la même pièce
dans l'ouverture koala mais pour clouer
le cavalier à 6 pour cloud cavaliers m6
avec une menace avec tout simplement
parfois la menace de
doubler les pions c'est à dire qu'on
menace quelquefois donc la prise sur m6
et la dame là dans cette position ne
peut pas reprendre parce qu'ils auraient
une fourchette donc on est obligé
d'ouvrir le roi d'accord donc et on
obtient un petit avantage en tout cas un
avantage à fait désagréables sur le long
terme
à partir du moment où on a deux
faiblesses dont sur une même position ou
si on aurait là le problème du lion de
ces 6 il y aura aussi le problème du
cumul 6 on sait que quand il ya deux
faiblesses jouer sur l'une ou l'autre a
été remis d'un mouvement de balancier et
amandes et peut-être faire craquer la
position si la cie à part des coups
tactiques
voilà donc on va revenir à la position
donc là l'ancien position avec le coût
des saintes et donc dans cette position
la théorie d'un entendu a évolué depuis
cette fameuse partie entre votre vie
[ __ ] talent et le coût principal dans
ça ne sonnait pas le goût de naturel
donc c'est le coup cavaliers des fêtes
c'est bon à savoir alors c'est bon à
savoir en même temps personnellement je
trouve ça très très surprenant puisque
déjà on va bouger une deuxième fois la
même pièce le cavalier on l'avait
développé en russie c'est maintenant une
vision 17
ici on a l'impression qu'on va pouvoir
prendront ces six créant le problème de
structure de pions telle qu'on avait
évoqué tout à l'heure c'est un coût qui
me paraît pas naturel mais van duc et
pourtant c'est un coût qui résout de
problèmes donc tu ne se résoud
directement le problème du contrôle de
la case au simple puisque le cavalier
sur 17 s'oppose à la venue du cavalier
sur cinq il y avait 10 h - cette fois et
je sois anticipe donc la présence et si
c'est à dire que là le cavaliere 17 6
ans et 6 3 6 sera très utile pour
soutenir l'option qui sera assurée 4,6
pour l'aider à avancer ça voilà sûr
c'est pas tout à fait et c'est là
effectivement on voit toute la
profondeur de ce coup c'est
qu'effectivement c'est une contre-mesure
positionnelle finalement compte une
prise anticipée du cavagnan c6 pas pour
qui tant médecin voilà effect vous
cavaillé 17 le coût normal
là on continue à se développer pour ces
huit donc ça c'est la théorie on
constate d'ailleurs que si on peut
prendre action avec les blancs on peut
prendre l'option le pion à sept
longueurs à 7
mais c'est très dangereux parce que
après un coup comme dame c8 la dame déjà
à se retrouver
géants menacent tout racisme n'est pas
très bien passé effectivement là elle
est excentré et latour aussi peut
éventuellement menace aussi de prendre
le cavalier sur ces 3 donc on va pas
rentrer dans les détails cette position
est dangereuse
ce qui fait que le coût normal après
tour c'est 8 c'est tout simplement de
roque et maintenant on joue à dix francs
et là on reprend de la tour donc on ne
peut pas reprendre du puits en
perforation tout de suite et on se
retrouve avec une situation où on n'a
pas de problème de structure de pions
non à des pièces qui se développe
maintenant tout à fait aisément
confortablement en un petit peu en
retard car il faut quand même bien
regarder la situation après tout absar
qui encore la théorie
flo7 les noirs sont un petit peu en
retard n'est pas suffisamment et ils ont
quand même la paire de faux aussi donc
ya pas mal de sensation il ya des
compensations
grâce à ce coup cavaliers 17 contrôle
quand même lesquels stratégiques qui
peuvent les embêter voilà donne à voir
la case aux cinq cavaliers 17 un conte
moderne qui traitent bien finalement ce
type de situation voilà alors ça c'est
intéressant de voir cet exemple pour
revenir dans la partie c'est dans la
partie on obtient une position qui
ressemble un petit peu donc dans la
partie on a donc et blanc jouait dame b3
qui pose ses petits problèmes
ola69 variante on aime bien d'analyser
foulée cinq maintenant on revient sur la
part progresse sur l'herbe et 10 octobre
et 3 et 4 donc là cette fois faut
décaper un coût normal et foulée 5 donc
finalement c'est à peu près la même
chose que tout à l'heure
sauf qu'au lieu d'avoir joué aux
cavaliers de cinq ont joué ou d'amd 3 ça
ressemble quand même à 7 des variantes
mais on joue un coût qui est un petit
peu moins un petit peu moins incisif que
dans la partie de votre vie nique ta peu
moins percutant exactement donc la petit
rock français si c'est là la position
devient elle fait amusant on doit
apprendre en c3 parce que le cavalier
sur cécile défendez-le fou on voit toute
la complexité des ouvertures moderne
maintenant où on voit qu'une petite
transposition peut changer radicalement
les volumes de l'évaluation d'une
position
oui hélas en même temps quand même sens
on s'inspire de ses vieilles parties ne
serait ce que pour avoir échangé donc
ces deux fous et essaient par ailleurs
de faire jouer ce fou et obtenir 2,7
cazaux 5 pour le cavalier on voit qui
est des thèmes qui reste malgré tout
donc d'enfants tour ses huit dont tour
c'est 8
là dans cette position ah non je ne veux
pas reprendre du pur il veut pas être
dominée par ses pulsions c'est bien
bloqué après il risque d'être en
difficulté
il est néanmoins on s'appelle un pion
j'ai l'impression set marion quant à sa
péremption pas dans toutes les variantes
en tout cas d'un gang dance qui est donc
parce qu'il ait joué oui là dans une
pétition cavaliers cinq cavaliers sainte
c'est encore la même idée l'idée c'est
empéché la prise de la tour on veut que
les noirs prennent avec le pion et se
retrouve ex option on va essayer
d'arriérés un pion faible et l'a donc à
nom de jouer la fameuse voir un petit
air un pion mais pour obtenir l'activité
et des compensation suffisante vous
plaît il joue cavalier 4 il aurait pu
jouer cavalier 4 c'est intéressant parce
qu'on a vraiment un combat de style
complètement différent on akrami qui est
un joueur très positionnelle très dans
la pressurisation il essaye de faire une
dépression des micros avantage et on a
en face le tigre de madras qui a pas
envie de se laisser faire et qui va au
contraire essayer d'obtenir des
compensations par une dynamique de
pièces quitte à lâcher un pion
effectivement il ya nombre de puits est
prêt à l'achat d'avions il aime bien le
jeu dynamique 1 c'est un joueur qui
préfère les lignes les lignes des
longues lignes tactique est assez
directe détendu c'est vraiment une aux
potiers la cram nick est peut-être un
style un petit peu subtil on pourrait
dire mais mais attendait comme
extrêmement brillant et un très très
beau jeu donc cavalier cap c'est pour
éliminer ce qu'avait dit sur les 15,5 et
récupérer la version 6 on échange des
pièces et l'a donc des caps
alors effectivement on pourrait
reprendre du pied ne pas perdre ses
options mais ce serait ce serait très
très mauvais stratégiquement puis cela
on voit que le pion c est à rire et donc
rien n'empêche au blanc de placer leur
tour sur la case sur la case c1 la seule
colonne ouverte et contrôlée par le fou
par l'info par l'om gâtera de casement
et donc toute la stratégie de 15 g nick
trouverez ici essence en fait exactement
ce qu'ils jouent depuis le début de
de la partie pour essayer d'obtenir un
pion isolé en face on sait si sur lequel
il va pouvoir après il continué une
pression de plus en plus accrue
exactement donc là dans cette position
tout repenser six dames 30 17
voilà donc ça c'est le position encore
intéressante puisque là dans sa position
anand a un un coup qu'on pourrait
appeler un coup naturel le ku'damm afin
que chaque donc ça ça fait partie aussi
un petit peu du jeu de crâne mikhail
pose des questions techniques et s'il y
aura peut-être des cas qui sont à leurs
yeux dangereux tout à fait donc d'amis
si on joue bep cap parce qu'il ya quand
même une tour c'est 6 1 voilà quittant
les rangs donc damas quatre pour
défendre la tour sur ces six là
maintenant les blancs jouent petit rock
tour v6 pour gagner le pion d'amis site
on prend bien sûr des six là tout
revient sur ces cas tout est obligée là
donc on voit que le variant de force et
qui donne un effet extraordinaire chatte
donc la tour vient ici et là le foot
bien sûr ces 5 donc il ya une égalité
matérielle mais le don déjà le fou dans
un premier temps enfin là la tour va
être rempli ce routard la pâte bonnes
cases en fait oui et en plus cela les
blancs vont pouvoir occuper la colonne
des le fou est bien placée elle le fou
sur cinq est mieux placé que sur gk pour
votre position les blancs sont un peu
mieux c'est surtout qu'on a une loi on
est une tour qui n'est pas noir laqué
pas très bien en place et on a une tous
réfutent il doit bouger qui a pas de
super case on est une tour on sekkat
qu'il cherche un objectif pour l'instant
pas pas claires et on est un fou g4 qui
fait qu'ils monde n'est pas super non
plus même s'il peut se replacer
effectivement dans cette situation là je
préférais également les blonds donc les
blancs sont un peu mieux et pour cette
raison nous gagnons on a joué un
excellent coup il a je le ku'damm s'est
vite tempère ces huit là il ya sa force
c'est changer d'âme parce qu'on menace
quoi directement comme on a doublé les
pièces sur la colonne c'est en menacent
de placer la tour sur la cafetière
c'est vrai que ça de prime abord ça
paraît surprenante propose un échange de
dames alors qu'il ya un pion - il qu'au
contraire ils essayent d'avoir des
compensations en terme d'activité caisse
plus active pour compenser le pion - et
pourtant les propositions des dames
mais effectivement ça ne ferait que
gagner un temps supplément
renoir puisque si la dame blanche vient
s'échanger ça ramène une nouvelle tour
sur la colline c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
est obligée à ces passeurs à partie donc
là on voit qu'il ya deux tours sur la
colonne s'est donc les noirs occupe la
colonne c est son mieux développer
puisque là le roi n'a pas encore brooke
et laurent blanc et il a probablement
pas l'intention d'aller au centre effet
conduire ce cette occupation d'un clown
c est une compensation suffisante pour
le pion de plus sur votre deuxième
question jean luc on a vu quand même des
variantes qui ont relativement forcément
il ya quelques qu'originaux mais je
pense que kramis pour mais s'attend
quand même un jeu de ce type lâcher chez
allende ami pouvait s'attendre à un jeu
de splash et anand tu penses qu'on était
encore dans la préparation ici ou que
cram mika s'était dit à fortes chances
qu'on arrive dans une situation qui va
s'annuler comme sur le plan stratégique
comment expliquer cette ce choix
d'ouverture j'ai quand même un petit peu
de mal à me à me dire pourquoi cramique
est entré dans une variante alors j'ai
regardé un petit peu dans les parties
récente des jouets dans cette ligne là
il ya peu de partis il ya assez peu de
partis c'est un travail plutôt
expérimental c'est une voix un petit peu
expérimentale c'est ce que fait krainik
en général donc aller tester un peu la
préparation adverse les variantes
l'habilité danon d'ajouts et des
positions un peu délicate un peu à peu
subtils comme ça donc je vais pouvoir
mais bon c'est là un petit peu aussi sur
lequel un psycho logique qu'ils
voulaient un peu testé un angle valeur
des prêts à entrer dans ce type de
configuration lâché un pion pour voir
s'il veut vraiment tester le tester
l'adversaire exactement il s'est dit on
sait jamais quelquefois c'est bien de
jouer ce genre de poser leurs questions
à l'adversaire en début de match bon
ceci dit quand ils utilisent une
cartouche blanche pour ce test là dans
ces seuils de son choix
est ce que c'est un match relativement
court c'est pas comme les matches
marathon qu'on pouvait connaître à
l'époque entre kasparov et karpov sur 24
parties c'est un match relativement à 20
ces cours ya pas une partie chaque
partie est très très importante cette
cartouche blanche est extrêmement tard
c'est très difficile de faire de la
psychologie web un match de tous partis
c'est surtout on n'a pas le droit à
l'erreur donc mais bon ça a été son
choix de toute façon illégale très
solide avec les noirs il peut se
permettre de se permettre avec les
blancs de tenter des petits pièges et
puis on sait jamais jamais jamais un
crack argent facile petites imprécisions
est telle qu'on connaît cramique quand
il a eu à faire face à des parties fines
à moins d'un décision devient assez
impérial derrière voilà il ya encore des
problèmes là les blancs au fond petit
rock à 5 4 c'est intéressant
la colonne c est bien occupé la h20 que
ça va être un disque destiné à stopper
l'avancée des pions blancs à les dames
contrôler la majorité blanche entre est
un chip et 4 il ya quatre ans en mettant
tout de suite un contrôle de la case des
4e lara donc f3 fou et cinq là dans
cette position
tour 1 donc la cram nique et décide de
préparer le coup eux quatre alors il ya
un petit piège dans cette position c'est
que s'ils fourest sur f5 il pourrait
jouer aux quatre avec un gain de temps
donc ça serait assez gênant si on
regarde cette position oui quelque chose
qui pourrait être bon à savoir c'est que
des coups comme tour f2 pour contrôler
la balle à la deuxième rangée donc
et là on se rapproche on se rapproche
très probablement de la nul après des
coups comme un échec
là on peut échanger et puis hippiques et
après revenir en c2 une fois voilà
aurait changé une perte de tours et là
on voit pas trop comment on est blanc
pourrait revenir en c2 la tour sur la
table en échange d'une paire de tours
la tour des censures et farina tout
revient sur ces 2 et une tour sur la
septième rangée ou sur la seconde rangée
c'est toujours très présent de tagab le
temps puisqu'une et blanc comptent pas
défendre le cube u2 avait tour bien à
cause de tourcoing échec suivi de fou
contours voir la très jolie donc tourner
un il y aurait tout reproche et deux
échecs avec donc une attaque à la
découverte
le fourgon qui récupèrerait la tour sur
ben voilà il donc là une position qui
serait devenu après complètement fan et
insipide on va dire fou de couleurs
opposées même monde de pions de part et
d'autre
qui serait on va dire morte tactiquement
exactement dans tout retour aux uns pour
préparer le quart de fouché 6b 3 donc
des trois coureurs c'est pas la peine de
laisser les pions sur la seconde rangée
alors que l'adversaire s'apprête à à
l'occuper à pénétrer la deuxième m6 la
bon c'est pour rapprocher le roi ça y
est ils commencent à pousser au centre
en échange la tour c 2 était un coup qui
était tout à fait correct je crois canon
dans cette mission il n'a aucun aucun
doute sur ses chances d'obtenir le demi
point
il décide de placer cette fois sa
deuxième tour face aux pions face
options avancées assez intéressant
finalement il décide de changer un peu
de fusil d'épaulé c'est à dire qu'ils ne
décident pas de pénétrer la par exemple
sur la deuxième rangée on est entouré de
il décide maintenant de faire pression
sur le pion quittant des cadres mais
parce que comment le défendre sur
l'avant ce repère immédiatement et si on
ramène le fou sur la case 3 on ne
contrôle plus le pur cap d'accord donc
en fait quelque part ça montre bien que
l'activité qu'il avait avec ses tours
était tellement importante que même une
même et ainsi cramique essaye de d'avoir
du jeu au centre en poussant la phalange
de pions f3 puis le 4 c'est maintenant
kramnik est dans une situation il va
devoir défendre ses pions sans trop et
ça c'est parce que justement un hand
avait une très forte activité grâce à
des tours magnifiquement voilà donc il
les défend comme ça maintenant à nantes
place sa trace sur la seconde ça c'est
normal et l'a donc kramnik doigts car il
commençait à faire un choix pour cette
position parce que qu'un pion qui
attaque et maintenant voilà il ya des
pions qui sera attaqué il ya une tour
sur la seconde rangée pour que ça peut
être délicat et l'a donc dans cette
position il a joué le coup et e5
il a jusqu'au 5 avec éventuellement donc
un oeil sur le pion aux 6 5 c'est
surprenant parce qu'on s'attendait
plutôt un levier on va dire des quatre
dessins qui aurait été plus dans une
esprit en fait offensif alors des 5000
c'était intéressant mais on peut bloquer
donc on peut poser des problèmes sérieux
puisque après un coup comme
5 le fou toujours par revenir sur la
case de 3 à cause du pian et 4 1 voilà
le pion à 2 et emprises et là si on
essaie de passer en force sur un couple
autour des deux qui est des champions à
deux et il permet aux fous donc
éventuellement de défendre la tour sur
des deux qui fait qu'après un échange le
four reviendrait sur une belle cars dans
l'île là il y aurait tout simplement un
coup comme tour ses huit donc défend la
tour le fou toujours attaquer et si on
essaye de pousser le pion alors avec un
petit piège surtout ce pion évidemment
c'est que le piège c'est que si on prend
le fou dans cette position le pion
avance encore et les tours ne peuvent
plus défendre il en perdrait la partie
donc ménard après donc l'avancée du pion
la tour revient sur la case c6 est
maintenant le foot doit choisir une case
enfin bon on continue à avancer
maintenant le choix de cadeaux se dit en
case la case d3 mais là maintenant donc
on ne peut plus un peu plus
véritablement tout tenir à savoir le
pion du 4l pur 17
ça devient délicat c'est très
intéressant c'est à dire
qu'effectivement la phalange de pion est
6 e 5 côté noir et très forte pascal
bride les velléités du fond blanc
adverses un coup et alors que le chou
qui est un geste de la part des noirs
lui et à plein potentiel puisqu'il est à
fond sur la faiblesse qui en a quatre et
c'est un fou qui est à mon avis
supérieur à son homologue
oui quelque part et cette position donc
là il ya au cari station grande
on essaie de jouer des coups comme ça on
prend même des risques là parce qu'elle
est noire a très bien entendu parce que
maintenant c'est le roi blanc qui son
coût d'une attaque double détour
effectivement avec une un plongeant 2
qui va être très faible plus le chou qui
va être sur casse blanchi là on a
peut-être même des réseaux et donc comme
tu parles de phalanges kramnik dons qui
lui a compris que dans cette structure
là il faut plutôt éliminer le curé cap
que le garder joue le coup aux cinq
l'accord effectivement ça c'est clair
il faut louer 5 donc j'en prends 1 505
tour prend à deux donc ça y est un
allemand de récupérer 100 pur en est là
la position va se neutralisent et
naturellement pour des cinq pour
défendre donc là on défend l'option afaq
là tout revient sur ses seins menace
éventuellement de venir sur la septième
rangée donc un land en joueur
expérimenté protège sa seconde rangée en
retour sa septième rangée
j'entends des sept tours c'est cinq
points quel point sur sur afin qu'ils
aient la tour à cette attente donc dès
qu'il aura l'occasion de ces zones de
gestion pour l'éliminer pour tout est
changé et il y aura plus assez de
matériel pour chronique après bien
compris ils pensent simplement de tout
échange et voilà donc toutes les pièces
sont échangées et cette partie se
termine par un match nul très logique et
c'est quand même très intéressant cette
partie c'est vrai que moi il était
surprenant que le choix d'ouverture
était surprenant mais on se retrouve
vraiment dans un style cram me tiens
j'ai envie de dire cram ni très
positionnelle on essaye d'obtenir des
micros avantage sur une position et en
face le tigre de madras toute la
dynamique qui a finalement très très
bien trouver les contre mesures par un
jeu très actif de pièces de tours et ça
ça a été totalement effectif suffisant
ici pour pour lutter contre la stratégie
voilà donc on une partie comme
légèrement insipide on attend quand des
choses je veux dire le grand maître et
le relance à commentaire est très très
déçu par cette partie oui mais c'était
quand même intéressant parce qu'on a
quand même dû effectivement un jour au
centre il y avait quand même des choses
intéressantes stratégiquement qui sont
sortis de cette position même si
effectivement s'attendaient peut-être ap
ira mieux et le meilleur reste à venir
sorti voilà donc merci nicolas refaire
une petite pause avant de reprendre la
deuxième partie à télé suite
eh bien tu es de suite en ligue
nous voici donc pour la deuxième partie
de ce championnat du monde de bonnes
notes 2008 à nom de cette fois râler
blanc et joue le coup un des quatre
alors ça c'est u2 c'est une grande
surprise
nicolas c'est vrai qu'elle n'en avait
plus tôt c'est plutôt un joueur de 4,1
en oui donc d'habitude à l'indien
commence par le coup 1re cape est en
général donc craint de nick lui répond
par des variantes très solide avec le
coup ou 4 5 1 qui correspond d'ailleurs
assez hostile dan andin qui aime bien
les positions ouvertes à tactique assez
en rapport avec son style de jeu 1 le
tigre de madras style de très tendue en
général voilà on imagine que l'indien a
peur soit éventuellement de la petrov et
je crois que récemment kramnik a plutôt
joué donc la variante de la berlinoise
dans l'espagnol
voilà donc cette position là avec
cavaliers m6 petit rock et cavaliers 4
exact et c'est vrai que ce championnat
du monde nous a réservé quelques
surprises
il faut noter quand même que les seconds
hand kramnik ce sont des joueurs de 4 à
1 et pourtant cramique joue des 4 alors
que hollande lui ou qui un joueur de
quatre jouent des cats on a quand même
quelques petites surprises dans les
ouvertures et donc là une défense ni
novik défense news the beach donc
cavalier 6 et 4 6 alors donc la défense
solide ce qu'on n'obtient pas qu'avait
laissé croire encore autre surprise
l'indien aurait pu jouer cavalier 3 un
couple standard pour partir vers une
défense ouest indienne pour partir vers
une défense australienne abc sous verre
argovie dames après après des cinq mais
il choisit donc à wc3 foulée 4 vous
pouvez 4 larmes favorite de karpov à la
grande époque et un coût extrêmement
répandu actuellement est une défense
d'ailleurs très très solide un essai à
la différence du capital
là dans cette position le cavalier donc
encore une fois où une pièce sur ces 3
et indirectement les 400 cas savoir le
cavadee comprend la case ou 4 donc f3
pour contrôler la case français encore
une surprise on ne sait pas jouer je
crois énorme
à un niveau tel que ce milliard face
joue rarement c'est une vague très
secondaire du du orbi de la défense très
solide
ça se joue peu mais c'est quand même un
coût assez dangereux comme sanef et
pourtant c'est un croquis qui
effectivement pas de piquant et qui est
assez logique avec l'esprit de la
position les noirs essaye de contrôler
un cadre qui essayent d'empêcher la
poussée libératrice entre guillemets
donc de 4 et f3 babala procès de lutter
également contre cette stratégie là on
veut essayer de prendre le centre est
quelque part va lutter contre les prises
de positions qui sont le fourbe et 4 et
le camélia 6 oui ça c'est un jeu très
très très direct on veut contrôler le
centre par 2 4 en tout simplement donc
des cinq un couteau logique sur f3 il
existe plusieurs petites variantes
on peut jouer d'autres coups sur f3 mes
dessins qui épingle la banque principale
il ya beaucoup effectivement bosser
cette année c'est à celle un pirate un
je crois la défense animer davantage la
défense les os x et qu'on peut jouer
blancs comme noirs beaucoup de soirées
entre eux faire son choix il ya deux
positions statiques à 3 donc à trois là
maintenant on va obtenir une position de
type ses miches avec le coup f3 donc la
péniche on va revenir en arrière pour
expliquer un petit peu l'ouverture
donc là cet est mis sur la mise au beach
c'est le goût direct à 3 très
entreprenant quand même on veut vraiment
posé la question aux côtés des quatre on
veut tout simplement prendre la paire de
fous là on constate à comprendre affaire
de fous la variante donc ses miches de
la news the beach c'est une des plus
anciennes puisque dans au début du
siècle dernier donc quand la défense in
the beach à ces parties d'éviter un peu
moderne cette période là on joué le coup
à 3 parce qu on ne doit penser qu'à
faire de foot des plus fortes
donc on
on voulait déjà testé voir ce que
pouvaient faire les noirs avec ce jeu de
cavaliers donc dans cette position c'est
un petit peu la même chose sauf qu'on a
joué le coup et f3 et tout tout tout
l'enjeu justement des noirs étant
d'éviter que le centre ne s'ouvre
complètement voilà continuer à essayer
d'exercer un très fort contrôle sur les
cases blanches notamment quatre pour
essayer de verrouiller par finalement
une dynamique de pièces le centre et
empêcher la perte de fous du grand blanc
de s'exprimer voilà donc on va on va
comparer cette position à la partie donc
on va voir que dans la partie après
juste essayé d'expliquer un petit truc
intéressant au niveau de la dette au
niveau de l'ouverture même
c'est donc on a à peu près la même
position sauf kf3 qui était jouée côté
blanc voilà il ya f3 qui a été jouée
côté blanc dans cette position donc si
vous avez cette position le coût
principal dans cette édition c'est le
coup c'est ça qu on ne joue pas des cinq
ans alors qu'elle est l'idée du coup ces
cinq pour nos éditeurs je pense
qu'effectivement c'est un coup
stratégique très intéressant quelles
idées noires alors que ici c'est vrai
que ça peut paraître un peu surprenant
les blancs peuvent peut-être poussée des
seins qu'elle est l'idée derrière c'est
simple formalité c'est tout simplement
de bloquer donc de bloquer pioncer cap
et là par exemple donc on va se
développer assez rapidement
par exemple après 7,5 en juin comme 3
qu'avait lycées 6 foot est roi
hélas il ne faut pas hésiter à jouer un
coup assez intéressant le coup le pro b
6 donc dans l'idée de jouer fois ci est
quelquefois cavaliers à 5 d'accord donc
ici en fait on a bloqué le premier quart
de la look et le pion c4 est maintenant
ou à jouer sur ce tube voilà d'accord
effectivement ici quand on regarde
maintenant cette position je vois un fou
en c1 qui est bloqué par ses propres
pions oui et un objectif d' attaque très
simple pour les noirs le pion ces quatre
ans qu'on a une stratégie assez simple
on essaye par d'un jeu de pièces de
lutter contre une dynamique à venir de
là d'une perte de chou adverse en
bloquant en solidifiant finalement la
structure des pions sur case noirs des
blancs de manière à pouvoir après échoué
sur les faiblesses c4 est par contre
dans cette position après donc
dépenser 3 dans la série des cinq n'est
pas le meilleur ou puisque c'est
évidemment là et froid n'est pas n'est
pas forcé on peut par exemple prendre le
pion qui après peut-être essayer de se
référer par c3 c4 avec la préparation là
exactement il est là on peut profiter la
paire de avec des f3 donc on est dans la
partie là dans cette position donc dans
ces trois reprises ces cinq donc ces
cinq c'est très naturel tout simplement
pour sortir le cavalier terminer le
développement commence a faire une
passion sur le sur le court central
on n'a pas peur d'ouvrir parce qu'on est
mieux développer évidemment entre nevers
de fou on déconseille de voir la
position mais là y'a le feu il ya le
développement des pièces c'est c'était
compensation suffisante tu reprends des
cinq cavaliers prend des cinq ans qu'il
prendrait la grande variante encore une
fois danser dans cet ordre la voie qu'il
prend des fois qui menace directement le
clan c3 directement que sur ces 3 et là
encore la grande lande puis on prend ces
cinq banques trop grosses à quoi peu
paradoxal puisque et double les pions
mais on a essayé donc il ya il ya le
russe alexei shirov qui avait lancé le
gundam détroit il ya pas mal d'années
donc là il ya plusieurs ou qui sont
possibles via le coup b6 calédonie comme
un point intéressant avec éventuellement
sur sur quatre l'idée de d'intercaler le
coup fois ci ce n'est quand même si
c'est à ce moment là on peut
éventuellement après derrière échangé le
fou donc cache la paire de fois l'
inverse tout en continuant d'embêter
dans d'arras et le camp blanc pour
empêcher qu'ils se développent
facilement exactement exactement donc
avec une position correcte pour les
noirs donc sur français s'arrête donc ça
c'est normal et la première surprise du
russe qui pour l'instant joue très
classique c'est le court abstract donc
le russe joue un coup surprenant mais
très logique est vraiment dans son dans
l'esprit de vladimir famille c'est à
dire trouver des flèches des subtilités
donc là le coup qu'on connaissait
c'était un massacre
direct qui est tout simplement basé sur
l' envie de récupérer un pion soit
l'option c3 soit le pion ses fins qui
appuie plus naturel peut-être dans un
sens ou défaire d'une pièce voilà et sur
dame sur dame afin qu'il nous semble que
la théorie c'est le carton confiance le
cavalier évidemment cavani pensée 3h est
interdit c'est une faute à cause pas
tête du cloud h au petit ancien
viendrait à non puisque la dame est
attaqué par oui oui mais la dame dit en
d2 ont tous qui cloue le cavalier voilà
sur la dame madame dit en d2 on la sent
simplement faux de et il ya d'énormes
problèmes donc on ne peut pas prendre le
pion est là en général il me semble
qu'on ramène le cavalier sur la case de
7 on peut peut-être le ramener aux six
ans m
bon là dans cette position je crois
qu'on fout ou 3 donc on joue feu trois
sur dame prend pioncer 3 le roi vient
sur f2 qui est pas forcément
effectivement il n'est pas forcément
nouvelle ska donc je crois qu'on va
plutôt essayer de récupérer le pion le
plan c'est par une neuve de cavani par
une manoeuvre de cavaliers cavaliers 17
par exemple on essaie de récupérer donc
l'option sur la case 124 cfp oui c'est
vrai qu'avec un cavalier en 7
on peut imaginer que ce cavalier va à
prévenir lui ont ces six et donc le
cavalier qui est en 8 peut effectivement
trouver une case en 17h04 et après donc
il faut qu'on a récupéré si on essaie de
jouer un petit peu sur les structures
mais c'est ça reste une vente comme
assez accès la mode c'est compliqué à
cette charpente cramique avait une
longueur d'avancé niveau d'ouverture il
a joué le coup et 5
alors c'est vrai quand on un peu de
recul par rapport à cette position si je
regarde bien c'est quand même quelque
chose d'assez surprenant on a quand même
des coups de pions assez atypique où à
côté blanc un pion lâche 3 on voit des
pions doublé sur la colonne ses côtés
noir ou un pion aussi un pion en f1
qu'avec des endroits qui a pas encore
dans les courants d'air mais on a quand
même des cases blanches sont un peu
inquiétantes alors ça paraît surprenant
refaire un petit peu le bilan on voit
wee cc certes surprenant mais dans cette
position là les noirs sont plutôt
relativement bien développé une pub rock
et ils peuvent requin un coût peuvent
bloquer en un coup ce qui n'est pas le
cas des blancs
donc les blancs leur seul avantage c'est
qu'ils ont une paire de fou et sont
aussi un pion de plus quand même même si
sa nature doublé c'est quand même un
pion et puis on a le pion aussi ce qui
peut aussi facilement arriver en 1 5 ha
voilà leur donner aussi un peu d'air aux
pour qui tant cible bon c'est vrai que
le coup elle cinq réponses semblent
répond tout à fait à la position on
continue de contrôler quatre c'est dans
l'esprit de la défense mindef 5 c'est
tout simplement si les noirs et les
blancs installe ce pion sur la case de 4
dans ces cas là on aurait éventuellement
la possibilité d'échanger déception ce
qui fragiliserait le pion sur eux car
ils seraient pas d y aurait pas ce qu'on
appelle une stature de pions et philippe
bach y aurait peut-être une heure un
coût des chèques peut-être avec dame je
me trompe adam h4 échec avait que huit
dames prend 4 derrière
oui oui tout à fait je parlais pas
exactement de 4 directement mais avec
préparation du char je parlais dans le
futur donc ça fragiliserait quand même
ça devrait quand même des ça permettrait
déjà gavés de pouvoir revenir sur la
case m6 donc le cavalier sur des cinq
ans à venir sa gazelle 6 en attaque en
option alors que s'il a évolué quatre
les normes on est blanc dans aucun
problème donc f5 incroyable sont mc2
l'aude mc2 ça ça défend le diront pas
l'oublier et ce après par le caue cas on
est vraiment dans une lutte à la mort /
ou contre la case à 4 depuis le début de
la partie et pour le centre donc validé
cet art maintenant les et noir veulent
récupérer le tueur le pion qui étend ses
cinq jeux mais rien dans ces 5 4 ça y
est on pousse au centre si on prend
pions qu'on cavani m6 donc comme ces
deux cents anticipé un petit peu la
défense du plan et 4 et maintenant donc
les blancs dans cette position juin coup
n'est pas surprenant mais qui est quand
même assez curieux c'est le coup ses
ciseaux qui en appelle ça un desperado
on envoie le pion
au casse-pipe plutôt qu'on va le prendre
et bien évidemment plutôt que de le
perdre en c5 en plus en remplaçant une
pièce qui tend 17 confortablement
on préfère affaiblir la structure de
pions adverse
voilà sacrifiant exactement on constate
que dans cette position c'est ce tour
disparaît la la colonne c'est appartient
au noir et donc qu'ils peuvent faire
pression sur ce deuxième plan j'imagine
que les tentatives désespérées par
exemple vous saignez environ trois pour
essayer de protéger ses cinq n'amène à
rien quand et blanc n'auront
probablement pas puisque déjà ya le curé
4 à descendre par la dame et la dame
noire de venir sur les 407 ou afin d'
pour continuer d'exercer la pression est
exactement donc ces six tout simplement
comprend maintenant les plantes se
développent cavalière froid damas cinq à
coki actifs qui est dans les oppositions
ou des deux alors d'amal fac aussi avec
une petite idée donc quelquefois on peut
essayer de chiper le pion sur la case
aux quatre quelquefois c'est la dame
reprend il y aurait peut-être un adhésif
est un échec
il répéta chat surveillance étroite
entre la dame on va ce pion et qui
attaquerait le roi la tour déjà des
petites idées comme ça aussi une autre
idée sortir ce fou donc soutenir le fou
pour s'échanger sur l'a46 donc éliminer
la berd fou on échangera une pièce qui
n'a pas beaucoup d'avenir sur surya
gonal puisqu'on voit qu'un pion sur
l'embout day
c'est vrai que quand on fait un bilan de
la position talk youtube explique
jean-luc a finalement les noirs par un
dynamique précise de pièces certes les
blancs ont réussi à mettre un pion sur
quatre ils ont ils y sont parvenus
mais le prix des quand même il est quand
même cher voilà il est il assez cher on
peut dire que pour l'instant ce je
considère que cette ouverture est quand
même plutôt réussie pour les noirs donc
fou des deux fous des deux ça fait quand
même une idée un petit peu logique c'est
sur x 10 6 là on va fermer la diagonale
et en attaquant la dame donc le pion
dans la diagonale et le fou attaque la
dame sur la fac donc le fou pour
l'instant n'est pas encore complètement
sortis d'affaires fr et en prévenir on
protège notre père de fonds
samson ou là par un garde l'a perdue
donc d'annoncer sa garde ses 5 ans pour
un coût très logique qui contrôle la
diagonale ou le roi et censé se mettre à
l'abri donc maintenant le défaut dans
des blancs c'est surtout le roi au
centre comment rockets voilà comment
routier dans cette position alors là pas
cette position donc kramnik à jouer
cavalier g4 cette position est
probablement équilibré 1 les
spécialistes sont tous d'accord pour
dire que à ce moment là les noirs n'ont
pas forcément de véritable problème est
ailleurs rauque et sans avoir peur du
couffo bk monkey b cap qui attaquent la
dame et par transparence
c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression qu'ici
les blancs bongani de qualité voilà mais
iliad à me 3 tout simplement échec force
les change d'âme en place la tour et la
honte non on joue ces cinq meilleurs
encore c5 qui fixe comme je l'expliquais
tout à l'heure le pion sur l'a4 c4 et
qui va faire parler les cavaliers et
l'activité des pièces cette année noire
en l'initiative du fait qu'ils attaquent
déjà une casse et que c'est après ce
sera à eux de jouer avec de belles
pièces donc ça des probablement une
position égal mais kramnik a peut-être
porter un petit peu plus en essayant de
garder pour l'instant les dames beckham
a pas que la dame dames trois dames eux
deux à ce moment là la position reste
quand même très équilibré grand roque
donc la cram nique à essayer donc ils
préparent peut-être un échange de dames
et la venue de ces cavaliers sur les
quinze centrales
on s'est peut-être trompé si ça dépend
tarder c'est quand même une position
très tendue en parce qu'il va falloir
que les noirs empêche le jeu en s'ouvrir
on pêchait que la paire de fou blanche
s'exprime et donc le fait que les noirs
propose les changes des dames
quand même et quand même étrange même si
correspond à l'esprit de la position ici
on a envie de garder des pièces parce
que le roi blanc est encore au centre le
roi blanc à par ok donc on a envie de le
garder encore un petit peu au chaud
envie de dire au centre est pour le
problème c'est qu'il faut aussi garder
l'initiative c'est quand cette position
sur jouer à notre goût peut-être que bon
il aurait peut-être pu essayer c'est
vrai il être puissiez le ku'damm v6
et dans ces cas là les deux joueurs ont
le même problème de placement droit donc
c'est un équilibre de la terreur en fait
par échange et les dames paraissent
assez compliqué assez tendue sans
compter qu'on peut peut-être
il ya peut-être fait les quelques fois
des tactiques à base de ces cinq qui
fermerait la décanale je sais pas la
position reste à un mac c'est tendu donc
dames 3 ça continue à garder le timing
le bon timing qui permet de se
développer et d'avoir la vence en terme
de sorties diane roy f2 donc là annonc é
rocha la main cavaliers g4 et qui
rockent à l'extérieur vont là dans cette
position unie peut se permettre
yapi dame sur l'idf dames et surtout il
n'y a pas de fous de 15 noir côté côté
noir justement voilà donc c'est pas
réellement un problème de venir ici en
g3 il peut pas il joua pas de c pas une
cible d'attaqués au nom donc la cram
milk qui décide dans sa position de
jouer compliqué il est il aurait pu
venir sur la case de 5 avec son cavalier
c'était probablement assez proche de
l'égalité en les blancs la paire de fou
mais les noirs sont précaires développer
et attaquant même dangereusement le
temps ses cadres et c'est là c'est un
petit peu le tournant de cette partie
c'est ce qui va donner un petit peu de
piquant à cette partie sept coups
cavaliers tf6 donc le coût qu'abd m6 qui
est une erreur mais ça donne du piquant
même de jeu des erreurs donc là il ya
une attaque directe c'est la tacc du fou
sur détroit donc le fou est venu sur la
case béant à coups précis a fait quand
même un peu étonnant un coup étonnant
puisque c'est vrai que ça empêche la
tour de se développer mais c'est
important puisque quand le foule venant
ces deux quelquefois lecavalier pourrait
venir sur trois étages mais d'adapter
les jeux vous continuer d'attaquer le
fou donc toujours pour garder
l'initiative là dans cette position
kramnik a défendu donc son cavalier pour
éviter éventuellement en fonction comme
lecavalier 6 décembre le cavalier sur
ses cartes à menace pourrait être
éventuellement le 5
la poussée du pion qui enlèverait un
défenseur et le roi oui mais répandre
dans notre cas même l'iran exactement 2
h 5 h 3 donc là anne on ne veut pas de
ces cavaliers et pose une question assez
importante au noir c'est ainsi par
exemple le cavalier revient donc sur la
case à 6
les blancs peuvent jouer un coup comme
cavalier 5 et est ce que le coût 4 5 1
avec un four qui pourrait éventuellement
ensuite plongé en d6 qui libérerait par
là même le fou de cases blanches qui
étend bien serait pas également un coup
dans candidats intéressants alors on va
voir ça c'est intéressant si de 4,5 oui
c'est probablement un cookie parce qu'on
fermerait quelque part la colonne des ce
qui est pas mal puisque pour l'instant
lé queens par une tour noire ça
repositionnerait le fou ou alors on ne
sait pas si c'est sa meilleure case mais
c'est pas une mauvaise case nu avec un
fou qui étend bien qui pourrait venir en
eux quatre puisque le pion 4 ou 5 va
chasser le canadien 6 oui c'est vrai
mais il faut voir quand même qu'il ya un
petit inconvénient c'est qu'on parle ici
on joue cavalier 17 la position vient de
compliquer le cavalier le pion c'est
qu'après attaquer et le cavalier sur des
ceps toujours des bonnes cases il est
déjà éventuellement ses statuts a offert
seulement attaquable donc la position
reste attendu alors que les quand on
joue cavalier 5
et puis il ya le coup il ya surtout le
problème du pion c4 évidemment kit
attaqué actuellement par le tout pour le
tout est pourri quand on joue cavalier
seul en attaque lui sur ses six ont des
fonctions ces cas et on domine surtout
donc le mode dominer et à un mot
important on domine le cavalier sur la
case cavaliers ne peut pas venir sur ces
trois caves puisqu'elles sont toutes
contrôlées par des pièces blanches on
voit que l'option contre la garde légale
le suricate contre l'a45 et le cavalier
contre la case sur f5 et c'est vrai que
lecavalier quand on première du cas il y
en a cinq
il est rayonnant un cavalier qui est
passé au centre de l'échiquier c'est là
où s'exprime le plus simple voilà donc
effectivement c'est intéressant
intéressant sur cavaliers 3 alors là on
vient de voir on vient de voir le coup
cavalia 6 / cavaliers 3 c'est la même
chose donc on domine donc ce cavalier
souvent dans cette position-là prise
alors là en plus on a quand même une
fourchette alors qu'un virage 6
contrôler mais là le cavalier menace de
bondir sur l'a47 et donc on arrive à
camaïeu 5 avec gagnent pas en fait voilà
et d'attaquer donc les deux tours là ça
passe vraiment de sérieux problèmes de
coordination
alors dans cette position sur h3 les
nouveaux les noirs doivent faire quelque
chose d'un peu
inhabituel ils ont sacrifié option zhu
hkm d'accord pour éviter justement
d'entrer dans cette variante compliquée
avec havas dieu singe et on est sacré
champion ce qui fait que la le cavalier
doit prendre le plan sur h4 et
maintenant on peut venir sur l'a15 aux
cinq qui était contrôlé tout à l'heure
qui est la case naturel d'accord on peut
l'occuper
c'est un chassé croisé entre les entre
les cavaliers blanc lundi cavalier noir
alors dans cette position and on doit
quand même être assez subtil il a gagné
encore un pion mais les pièces noires
sont quand même très active
donc il ramène son cavalier sur f3 pour
échanger lecavalier sur cinq
c'est ce que j'avais à dire en fait la
gagner il a quand même gagné quelques
tempo il a gagné quelques temps certes
il a lâché un pion sur la colonne h
mais quelque part ça ça donne un peu
plus de jeu à la tour qui est en ma
cheville
voilà le cavalier noir arabe lui puisse
se positionner sur cinq alors que
c'était une case qui semblait prédestiné
pour le cavalier blanc donc il a coupé
un peu l'herbe souquet des joueurs
blancs et il a obtenu quelque part un
meilleure dynamique de pièces tout à
fait alors là on voit que les
oppositions les besoins se précipitent
pas sur le tour c4 se précipitent pas de
sanction c4 parce que ça peut être très
dangereux la tour pourrait venir en c1
et les pièces peuvent devenir actifs par
rapport aux options si ce qui est faible
et éventuellement le cul russie ce
savoureux rennes et des gones à l'oph où
ils ont préféré jouer un coup comme
cavani h5 cavrois f2 échanger sur f3
3.93 donc encore une forme en patience
et cas parce que si on jouait comme vous
pour ces 4 est bien là il ya un goût
comme tour c1 avec le pion prise et on
ne pourrait nuire à le défendre voit pas
le protéger puisque si on joue b5 à
l'union voilà à trois à quatre derrière
à venir voilà tout à fait il ya des
coups à capter avec l' avantage donc
dans cette position on doit rester avec
la viande - mais il faut faire quelque
chose parce qu'elle perd de fou dans une
position relativement ouverte et crame
ni dans cette position a trouvé un coup
qui a fait excellent oppositionnel
d'éthique
il a joué le coup et cinq alors le coup
ça que c'est un très bon coup parce que
ça ça plante en fait sa fiche
complètement le pion e4 et du coup le
pauvre fou qui était en b1 et bien n'a
pas énormément de charisme
on est là pour ça
ça dérouille de diagonale du fou
simplement et en même temps ça permet
aux cavaliers de qui et sur l'a 15 h 5
ça lui donne un chemin pour venir sur
des c'est vrai qu'ici on a des cases
necas centrale à lui permet de rebondir
et de venir sur des belles cases
donc c'est un coup intéressant pour ça
donc là il maintenant il défend son pion
cavaliers à quatre tours a deux bons ils
se développent comme il veut simple et
logique cavaliers detroit alors dans
cette position après cavaliers detroit
ici les les noirs peuvent se débarrasser
de la perte de fou adverse mais je sais
pas si c'est alors les blancs et les
voilà je ne sais pas si c'est ce qui me
exactement jouer dans cette situation
qu'elle est quelle est l'idée en fait
derrière et derrière cavalli des trois
mois qu'il y ait des trois c'est
probablement désorganiser la position
des blancs puisque avec leur père de
fous ils menacent tréviers leurs pions
plus ils menacent d'avoir très très vite
un gros avantage donc là dans cette
position si par exemple on prend et
c'est vrai que c'est surprenant parce
que cavani détroit quand on voit le foot
qui quand bien même ils seraient presque
content de l'échanger contre ce cavalier
ah ouais mais si on prend prises les
noirs dans cette position garde une
certaine initiative parce qu'on a quand
on se débarrasse des cases blanches
après il faut assumer il faut assumer la
défense de tueries capta défense du thon
ces cas on peut l'assumer éventuellement
en juin comme moi j'ai 4 mais ça reste
quand même assez tendu où un tout
cohérent poser comme ça avec le roi un
petit peu le roi qui peut devenir actif
certes mais un encore deux tours en fait
il ya quand même peu après guerre où il
ya plein de renvoi c'est celle par
exemple l'histoire de quelques fois
romaine le fou sûr c'est évident
beaucoup de choses sont possibles dans
cette position c'est pas vraiment le
sida non de prendre des risques donc
tour ces trois coups logique quelque
part cavani détroit a rempli sa mission
c'est à dire un petit peu
faire fonctionner le placement des
pièces des pièces blanches la lecavalier
donc qui attaque et revient sur l'a15 f4
et on voit peut-être que là par exemple
la tour pourrait éventuellement bondir
sur la case pénétrer sur la case [ __ ]
là sur la case d1
donc cette position and on n'a pas envie
de ça il aurait pu jouer tous rêvent de
mai n'a pas envie de décider activités
il préfère je fous ces deux quitte à ce
que sa tour ne joue pas pour l'instant
c'est un choix intéressant il a joué un
coup quand même relativement intéressant
qu'avait lieu six mots claquent radnic
maintenant on ramène ce cavalier là avec
une très belle cagade ici effectivement
sur quimper des quelques jours cette
idée échanges et donc d'échanger de se
débarrasser de ce casse blanche
logiquement à nant deux décident de
replacer son roi pour éviter l'échec sur
laquelle des quatre ont pour éviter
toutes toutes possibilités tactiques on
va venir sur les chèques
voilà et là dans sa position donc
krainik a joué tour des quatre donc tour
des quatre qui attaquent le pion c4 et
une belle case pour la tour évidemment
alors dans cette position kremnica
proposé nul et l'indien on avait plus
que trois minutes pour terminer la
partie donc
l'indien a décidé d'accepter acceptait
la proposition il n'a décidé d'accepter
la proposition alors ça c'est un choix
qui à mon avis est quand même assez guy
qui est justifiée peut-être par rapport
à la situation dans la partie mais qui
techniquement par rapport à cette
position est un peu à justifier je pense
que cette position
l'efs favorable aux rouges blancs il y
avait encore matière à faire je vois
quand même que la stratégie qui était
opéré par les noirs étaient vraiment
conforme quelque part à l'esprit de
l'année de vix bon sens où on a toujours
eu une forte dynamique de pièces noires
sur cette partie il ya toujours eu un
avant et un avantage de développement
assez important et à ces montants
le foot case blanche a toujours été
verrouillés côté blanc c'est vrai que le
fou il est en bien là il est bloqué par
son pion au no 4 il ya quand même une
une
j'ai envie d'une stratégie très
positionnelle de la part des noirs pour
bloquer pour lutter contre la paire de
fou adverse et ça a été payant quand
même même si effectivement la position
à mon avis détient encore pas mal de
possibilités
quelque part bravo à g nick un bravo à
kamnik mais bon on va on va quand même
regarder un tout petit peu plus loin là
par exemple si on joue un coup comme
tours b 2 c'est pas évident quand même
alors il ya un gros piège là c'est
qu'après tournée de france et cap
la noire pour l attention parce qu'ici
il ya là il ya des prix ce possible avec
voilà les connaît bien ici et il est
bien ce qu'il en est là exactement et
ont même pu sauver 3 avec transparence
d'actu quatre ans l'attak du cavalier
sur os 6 donc là on ré perdant
directement après tour b26 on échange
des tours par exemple en augmentant ses
gains après il peut y avoir des petits
problèmes après des coups comme food et
6 par exemple ce que tu as nous dit un
champ luxe et que la perte de tout
commence maintenant à parler à ses
caprices ont fini par s'ouvrir et et
quelque part c'est un peu frustrant
c'est à dire que anne on n'a pas pu
faire parler sa paire de fouet au moment
peut-être où il commence à y avoir des
possibilités d'ouvrir le jeu et de la
faire parler cette paire de fous ils
l'acceptent l'annulent de cramique ans
il faut mettre en contexte de du match
c'est la deuxième partie là il reste
comme a joué sept qu'on ne le croit
troisième oui par rapport aux contrôles
tant il reste encore sept coups à jouer
ap tour d2 pour sortir du contrôle
banques
il n'a plus que 3 minutes et krainik
d'avoir plus de temps à ce moment là
donc bon et puis je pense qu'elle est
aussi pas mal encore de ressources côté
noir c'est vrai que le cavalier qui peut
se tait en d4
quand même pièce qui clairement
supérieure qui était encore à ce moment
l'ambiance et de pardon donc donc une
proposition de nuls accepté par parra
nand et c'est vrai qu'on est resté un
petit peu sur notre faim sur cette
deuxième deuxième partie on est un petit
peu sur notre faim bon c'est vrai que
pour l'instant à nom de annoncé comme un
petit peu plus
un peu plus agressif puisqu'on si on
compare la 1ère partie la deuxième je
crois que c'est assez évident que le
joueur en forme c'est plutôt l'indien
puisque directement avec les blancs ils
passent à l'action
ah c'est vrai que la première partie
c'était une variante des changes du
gambit dame s'était pas très pas très
passionnant là il a accepté d'entrer
dans le réseau d'eau dit il c'est que la
défense dynamique c'est quelque chose
d'assez tendue c'est très solide et qui
donne lieu à beaucoup de passes tactique
et je pense qu'effectivement un an de
recherche la confrontation à nombreux
cherchent la confrontation astrale vous
pour cette deuxième partie
merci d'être venu pour faire des
missions merci jean luc c'est un plaisir
et et à très bientôt mais que tu as très
bientôt